hey everybody it's that Thanksgiving
time of the year isn't it and while
you're stuffing yourself with turkey and
stuffing and potatoes and can-shaped
cranberry sauce you can also stuff your
eyes and your mind with a bunch of viral
content pertaining to that magnificent
holiday take it away yeah but Jason the
wet weather might be the story this
weekend yeah this weekend really is
going to feel not even like mid October
it's going to feel like late October
dare I say even uh the nword what did he
say
November it took me a minute you guys
are ruining Thanksgiving and it's my
second favorite holiday right after
pretend not to notice People's race day
have you seen Reggie around which one is
Reggie oh uh well today he's wearing
yellow pants uh yellow shirt yellow hat
yellow shoes uh he's got a gold tooth uh
diamond earring um he's got that big
necklace with a dollar sign on it uh
he's always grabbing his crotch when
he's telling a story like the one about
when he found out his mother is really
his grandmother you be more specific uh
oh let's see uh he always wears cheap
cologne uh drives a Mercury Cougar with
a crown on the dashboard uh never Pays
His alimony uh he's extremely cut for a
guy who never works out oh there he is
thanks anyway hey
Reggie you see there at the end it kind
of it inverts your expectations what
were you thinking H I wasn't thinking
anything yo what's up
[Laughter]
[Music]
bro this well
done great job a large black coffee a
what large black coffee do you mean a
ventti no I mean a large he means a
ventti yeah the biggest one you got
venty is large no venty is 20 dny yeah
large is large in fact tall is large and
Grande is Spanish for large venty is the
only one that doesn't mean large it's
also the only one that's Italian
congratulations you're stupid in three
languages pretty rude but it's true
Fenty means 20 did you know
that 20 o 20 hey
kids look what I got
got dad what is this that's just regular
boring ass Pizza dad more like dork no
wonder mom left with pizza like
this you're a
joke hey
kids look what I got sa bottom say
goodbye to boring ass Pizza snag a dad
win with Domino's new sauce bottom Pizza
my mouth is blown the sauce is on the
bottom so it can slam your flavor buds
faster you know what I'm glad mom
left this pizza is so good Dad I'm gay
yeah that's how we do it also try our
jalapenos poppers only at
dominoes it's so well done is it's all
just a little bit off that's really are
we we're entering the daada period of
American
[Music]
art you know hezel is very smart they're
all very
smart hezb is very smart that's the
Republican candidate's position Lawrence
calling a person or a group of people
very smart doesn't mean you're embracing
them for example Iran made Joe Biden
send them billions of dollars Iran is
smart Joe Biden is dumb let me give you
another one MSNBC your outlet made half
of the country believe in the Russia
hoax MSNBC is is a smart but at the same
time you are still a fake news piece of
Outlet
uh for the first few seconds I thought
it was an actual interview but it's a
good point that he made very good
point good
[Applause]
point
[Music]
that could almost get me to like soccer
that bit of Whimsy almost
never well a very very heavy heavy
dtation tonight we had a very Dar
darrison B let's go to terce Tas for the
B the head the pet I'll admit
maybe couple times in my life I may have
articulated the English language in a
similar way Gibble gobbley chicken pop
[Music]
[Applause]
pop
[Laughter]
tequilo
perfect perfect
execution don't you see how this could
be offensive to a real authentic Mexican
hey can I just say that I'm Mexican and
this doesn't bother me at all cuz these
tacos are great okay sir uh I appreciate
your feelings on on the matter but I
don't need you to be a mouthpiece for an
entire Cuisine okay as long as a white
man's doing the cooking I won't be
eating here oh I'm not the cook uh guo
is the cook GMO excuse me senor you
don't need to work here you can open
your own taco truck uh GMO doesn't speak
English
um I'm just surprised you actually don't
know what to be offended by right now do
you I this is it's like watching a
computer glitch I don't know what movie
that is but it's a documentary I have a
banana peel on the ground I'm going to
see if it's really slippery like it is
in the
cartoons I don't believe he really had a
banana peel there I've laugh harder at
videos but that was still
funny you
[Music]
make
well well well
[Music]
you I'm only at the middle step of that
right now and I can confirm that's true
it's the word of the day today's word
is
enormous very large in
size so like something that's really big
like an elephant okay you tell me what's
something that's
enormous Daddy
B I said
Daddy I think we all saw that one coming
what's most interesting about this one
to me is it's that's actually not what
what enormous means a lot of people
think that's what enormous means but
enormous connotes wickedness so you
would say the plot hatched by the
terrorist group it was an enormous plot
it was the the enormity of the attack
was what there's a it denotes size but
also has this kind of evil Bad
connotation to it which has been lost
because people don't read their shrunken
white anymore there's nothing shrunken
about you dearest because democracy
basically
means government
by the people of the people for the
people but the people are
many many political
philosophers throughout history have
struggled to articulate what that man
articulated in just a handful of
words I hope you enjoyed sitting here
with me watching me watching videos
about
food we see see you next
time